hello and welcome to this video playing
sha hist a-okay 93 I've against you six
a GUI form now well it's a funny
transposition yeah okay see three I
think is good for white but can also
play my Roxy for a change he might not
take there are a couple of offbeat lines
but he takes 26 okay
don't believe in moves like that all
that much I mean it's certainly playable
but
at the end of the day I will win a
temple back on the Queen the night on b3
is not that badly placed okay so if I go
94 now we are back into a main line
exactly the main line let's do it come
on
yes - quacks excellently in the main
line
why don't need to do anything fancy
may I probably had something better than
90 forward this is a simple way to play
b8
huh so he wants to take and then play b5
I guess
okay
it's an interesting concept how do we do
that for a for looks a little bit it
looks a bit too crude
don't be three before I see if there is
before that is a really annoying thing
okay
don't really find anything good so I'm
playing something normal I should have
played this quicker I guess
[Music]
we interesting plane
it just takes it with the bishop okay
I'm expected be takes but this is of
course fine move
b5 is sir is on the cards so 95 I guess
and I'm okay it's not like I'm in
trouble I don't think so
but when the usual scenario is just like
in the maroc see I'm just dominating and
win I don't know what this doesn't
happen here at all I think nothing much
is going on I wanted to go up to see one
but this is actually not not that great
I mean I have to probably do it actually
but Queen 8 to Queen c7 I don't think he
can afford that
no cuz Age 5 yeah okay I mean there's
really nothing going on but if he trades
I will play the same game so for win and
I have one dos endings a lot so at least
I can try
okay
you know what he's doing there is he
going for d5 I don't think so
sighs hmm
okay
where that is true that is actually true
I didn't didn't really had this move on
the agenda or that much
I scored a four I'm playing this like a
completed yet what am I doing here I
mean that ah what an awful game I mean
losing in this opening always who has a
double because you cannot it was
normally and I really managed manage to
do it what an idiot I am
so a it's really difficult to loosen the
maracas see
my goodness
what a terrible game oh my god there was
betting in the ending I mean not
impossible to lose Bettis is the wrong
way to put it but the only one who can
try this is me of course
what a terrible game what an idiot I
mean like here in this ending I mean if
anybody white has slight chances to play
for win and I play it sold or whatever I
am and losing oh my god this is awful
this is really awful so I came gaining
the space I don't think can be wrong
many went is 6 g Jake jabs should be a 3
is extremely slow and you know I thought
about a 5 briefly but not ever me
promise was I was just playing it in a
far too slow way like like I have all
the time and this really wasn't the case
ok 5 King King King B 3 yeah I mean this
is just like terrible this is a terrible
move
and after f5 I'm clearly better
according to the comp which I find
surprising actually like why is that
clearly better g4
hmm
still hard to believe that this is
something then before king of three
have a hard time to believe that I'm
better than him and when I want to check
first how I screwed this up I mean that
how it's really difficult to lose a game
in this opening if I was just like I've
just played like totally you've totally
moronic and that burned enormous amount
of time at the very beginning we're
trying to to play something challenging
yeah I should play a five-year
that'sthat's pretty clear now Gahee I'm
just I just totally lost the plot I mean
totally just a little bit of thought
would have been enough I mean like
Bishop III is just awfully here's a
4-course I mean even this simple move
was okay after a for if everything else
fails I can take here well why is that
losing because of crusher takes b3 that
is very nice it's very nice mm-hmm
very nice trick but this is holding yes
honing that society is it hurts
extremely it's too loose against this
opening not that detect is so bad for
black becoming I never lose against it
really basically and this is one of
those cases where you like Jim it was
interesting that he just played a six
and never took on d4 age three is a
recently popular line that is quite
interesting and I couldn't quite figure
out how to play here and now it's really
interesting
[Music]
but I have absolutely I don't have
anything in a way but I should have done
the release of the quicker you know here
I was thinking about this but he didn't
do it
Jim Jim this is of course very very
equal issue you should absolutely not
lose really not g-force also good move
here this is better than then age phone
because he basically has to take and
then I can try to get G five and a
forehand yeah anyway still disgusted at
I lost his position anyway thanks for
watching